GARTH NIX: I'm going to
talk for a little bit.
I'm going to read a
couple of short things,
and I'm very happy
to take questions.
I often think that you'll
get more out of the questions
anyway, and I will discover
what you actually want to know,
as opposed to me just talking.
Stefan asked me about
the origin of my name,
so I thought I would address
that very quickly, because it
is, in fact, the question
I get asked the most.
It is not the question
that always get
asked, which is, where
do you get your ideas?
That actually comes second for
me, because the question I get
asked the most is, "Is
Garth Nix your real name?"
Because it sounds
like the perfect name
for a writer, particularly
a writer of fantasy,
so everyone always presumes
it must be a pseudonym.
I must have made it up.
Other authors,
particularly, assume
it must be a pseudonym
because it sounds so right.
And it's short.
It fits very nicely
on the books.
It's in the middle
of the alphabet.
There's a whole science
of picking pseudonyms.
Authors like to talk
about what pseudonyms
they'll need to adopt at
some point in their career,
or want to adopt.
And one of the theories is
that you should always--
and this is, I guess, an
all time theory, really.
Obviously less relevant now.
But you should choose a
surname which is roughly
in the middle of the alphabet.
Because when the books are
on bookshelf, bookstore,
and they go A from the
top left corner down to Z
in the bottom right, you're
roughly in the middle.
You'll be at eye
height, and your books
will be even more prominent.
Doesn't work so well in this
era of online selling and so on.
But Nix, roughly in the middle.
People assume it
must be a pseudonym.
It is, in fact, my real name.
It is my real name.
My parents claim I was not named
after the comic book "Garth."
I don't know if many of you
know that comic series which
ran in the '50s and the '60s and
the '70s in "The Daily Mail,"
I think, in the United Kingdom.
But it also did run
in the "Herald Sun"
in Melbourne, where
I was born, so I'm
deeply suspicious about
my parents' claims
that I was not named after
Garth, who was a super hero who
could travel back in time and
has adventures in many places.
And my family always
found it very amusing
that the super hero Garth has
an enormously muscled body
and a very small head.
Whereas I'm quite the reverse.
I have a very large head
and am not so muscle bodied.
So it is my real name.
It is the perfect name
for a writer of fantasy.
I think it's also the perfect
name for a writer in general,
in part because
you can find both
my names in the dictionary.
So I'm always very
pleased about that.
Both my names actually
have other meanings
that aren't just names.
A "garth," of course,
is a walled garden
or a walled courtyard.
Like a cloister
garden in a church.
"Nix," on of the meanings
of nix is, of course,
nothing, which I
prefer to ignore.
Mr. Nothing.
Hi, Garth Nothing here.
Not so good.
But much, much,
more appropriately
for a writer of
fantasy, it is also
a very old word from
Germanic mythology that
means a merman or
a water sprite.
I love the definition
of Britannica,
"Encyclopedia
Britannica," the best.
It has a really great
light on what Nix is.
[INAUDIBLE] dot com
has it and so on.
And according to myth, a nix
is a creature half human,
half fish, that lives in
beautiful underwater palaces.
And they're able to
assume human form.
And typically, they
assume the form
of an aged crone, a young
maiden, or Australian author.
And I've always loved the
idea that perhaps long ago,
one of these mythological
nixes interact
with humans in two ways.
That they don't have a
great range of feeling.
They only interact in two ones.
One, is they like to lure
humans to death by drowning.
Not so positive.
And the other one
is they marry them.
It's like one or the other.
It's death or marriage.
Not a lot of choice.
You can't be friends, it seems.
But I like to think
maybe a long time ago,
there was one of these
mythological Nixes, chose
marriage, and maybe
I'm a descendant
from a mythological
creature as well.
So absolutely perfect
for a fantasy writer.
So that's my name.
That's my name in a nutshell.
I thought I'd read a couple
different little things today.
The first thing I thought
I would read, just
to give you a basis
for comparison,
is, in fact, from my very,
very first published book.
Admittedly, self-published
book, because here it is.
"Stories" by Garth Nix.
And I made this little book when
I was seven or eight years old.
And I wanted to tell stories.
And obviously, I was also
thinking about publishing.
I was a long way ahead of the
whole self-publishing thing
that goes on now.
It was easier back
then, of course.
You just folded up
a piece of paper.
So I want to read you a story
from "Stories" by Garth Nix,
and you can see if I'm
improved over the years.
If you tell me this is the
best thing I've ever written
and it's been downhill ever
since, I'll be disappointed.
So this is a little story.
I wrote it when I
was seven or eight.
It is quite long.
So settle back.
You can relax and
I'll read it to you.
It's called "The Coin Shower."
"A boy went outside.
It started raining coins.
He picked them up.
The end."
So it's not that long.
But one of the things I
like about this little story
is that it shows that even
back when I was seven or eight,
I was thinking about the
structure of stories.
Because that has a very
classical story structure.
It has a beginning
where a character
is introduced in a setting.
There's a boy who went outside.
Then there's a middle, where
there's a complication.
It started raining coins.
And then there's the end, where
I resolve the complication
that I've set up.
He picked them up.
So even back then,
obviously from the books
that I'd been reading, from
the stories I'd been reading,
I was instinctively absorbing
the structure of stories.
This isn't the actual "Stories"
by Garth Nix, by the way.
Because the real one is in the
National Library of Australia.
Not really.
The real one is back home.
My younger brother
actually found it.
About for years ago,
my parents moved.
My mother rang me
up and said, you've
got to come and help us pack up.
But most of all, you've
got to come take away,
or organize to take away,
all your boxes of books
that you have underneath house.
And I hadn't lived there for
25 years or possibly longer.
I thought, boxes of
books under the house?
I said, well, what
are we talking about?
Because I could remember
three or four boxes of books.
And my mother said, 21.
I was like, oh.
Whoa.
21.
I wonder what's in there.
And so I went down.
And, in fact, there
were 22 boxes of books
that I had to remove.
And while we were
helping pack up,
my younger brother
found this little book,
or the original of
this little book.
And he got it out while
we were having lunch
and he started reading some
of the stories from it.
And I thought that he'd made
it, just to make fun of my.
My brother.
So he was just poking fun at me.
You're the author.
He just wanted you to see
some of your early rubbish.
But my parents didn't
know, that actually is.
That's a real thing.
He hadn't made it up.
It was a real little book.
But I couldn't
remember exactly when
I made it, when I
was seven or eight.
Something like that.
So even very early
on, I was obviously
thinking about being a writer
and planning to be published,
but I had to do
it myself or not.
So "The Coin Shower" is
very early Garth Nix.
And I thought I might
read your something now
from "Clariel," much
more recently, of course.
"Clariel" is a return
to the Old Kingdom.
It's a return to the setting
of "Sabriel," "Lirael,"
and "Aborsen," and a couple
of the longer short stories
that relate to
that world as well.
But it's a very
different Old Kingdom.
The world of the Old Kingdom in
"Sabriel," of course, the Old
Kingdom is shattered and broken.
The dead have come back from
death all over the place.
There are Free Magic
creatures on the rampage.
Everything is in big trouble.
But in "Clariel," it's
going back 600 years
before the events of "Sabriel."
And the Old Kingdom is,
in fact, very peaceful.
It's very settled.
It's rich.
There's no trouble,
no apparent trouble.
Because of this,
people have largely
forgotten about the danger
presented by the dead,
by the ability of things
to come out of death.
They've forgotten about
the Free Magic creatures.
There hasn't been any
trouble for such a long time
that everyone's got
used to being peaceful.
And as a consequence
of this, the Abhorsens,
the family whose job it is to
keep the dead down, to deal
with the Free Magic
[INAUDIBLE] and so on,
have become much less important.
People don't think of
them as important anymore.
Charter magic itself has become
something that people are not
so interested in
because it's hard.
It's difficult to learn.
So it's something that
you get other people
to do rather than
learning it yourself.
It's something for service
that you pay to do.
So it's a different world.
And "Clariel" is the story of
a young woman called Clariel
who has grown up
in a small town.
And who is a loner.
And she's solitary.
She loves the forest.
She wants to be a hunter.
She's 17.
Her idea of her future
is to live by herself
in the Great Forest.
Perhaps to become a
border, one of the people
who patrol the forests and
make sure that all is well.
But it's still an essentially
solitary occupation.
But she's forced to move to
the capitol city, Belisaere,
by her parents.
Her mother, Jaciel,
is a goldsmith.
A very, very talented
goldsmith who was given
the opportunity to join the
high guild of goldsmiths
in Belisaere, the capitol city.
And, in fact, there's
a very nice new map
of Belisaere in "Clariel."
It's always nice to have to a
new map in any fantasy novel.
This one actually has
the old maps, as well.
So it has three maps.
Any fantasy novel
with three maps,
it must be three times as
good as one with only one map.
And possibly 30 times as
good as one with no maps.
That probably
doesn't really work,
but it's a very nice new map.
So she's forced to go to
Belisaere with her parents.
Her mother makes her go.
She hasn't been in the
city very long before she
realizes that she has to escape.
She has to get out.
She feels crammed with
the walls, the people.
She's disconnected from
the life she really,
really wants to lead.
So she decides
she'll do whatever
is necessary to escape the
city, get away from her parents.
And her parents are powerful.
Her mother is a
cousin of the King,
as well as being high on
the goldsmiths' guild.
She's also the daughter
of the current Abhorsen.
Clariel is the granddaughter
But they are estranged
from the Abhorsen family
for reasons that become
clear in the story.
So Clariel has a lot
arrayed against her.
Her parents have
particular plans for her.
They all involve being stuck in
the city, surrounded by stone.
She can't get out under the sky.
And she decides to do
whatever it takes to get out.
And one of the opportunities
that presents itself to her
is that if she can help a small
group of people do something,
they will help her.
And what this group of
people wants her to do
is to help them track what they
think is a Free Magic creature.
They think there's a Free Magic
creature on a little island
just outside the city, which
is getting into the city.
They want to know
what it's up to.
This is a small group.
They're among the few
people who are actually
concerned about such
things in this current era.
So Sabriel-- Sabriel.
I've been on the
road for a month.
I'm getting a bit
tired, obviously.
If I start talking
absolute rubbish,
I'm sure I'll be taken
away and wet cloths will
be applied until I
made sense again.
Clariel agrees to help
them, not really fully
understanding what she's doing.
They think that because she's
the Abhorsen's granddaughter,
and the Abhorsens
are very deeply
connected with the
Charter of Free Magic,
that she can be used
like a tethered goat
to draw the Free
Magic creature out,
which is, of course, a much,
much more dangerous thing
than she really knows.
I'm going to read a little
passage to you where's
she gone with this
group of people
to this little rocky
islet to try and lure out
this Free Magic creature.
And, of course, things
don't go exactly as planned.
So I'm going to read a
little sequence to you.
"'Lady Clariel,' a human
shout, followed by the rush
of footsteps on stone.
Roban came charging up
the steps, sword in hand,
silver fire leaping
along the blade.
At the same time, something else
rose up out of the very rock,
almost under Clariel's feet.
At night, from a distance, it
might be confused for a woman,
for it was vaguely
feminine in shape.
But this close, it could be
seen that the slender legs ended
not in feet, but
narrowed to become sharp,
burning blades the
color of yellow teeth.
"Its arms had two elbows
a hand's width apart.
And its spade-like hands
had too many fingers,
each ending in a
curved back claw.
Its hair was not
hair, but a mass
of brilliant tendrils
of white light
that flowed around its
head and cascaded down
its shoulders and back.
And its face, if it
had one, was an absence
of light in the middle.
A dark, oval void without
features of any kind.
"Below its shining
head, its skin
was entirely the color
of old, dried blood.
Claws raked at Roban.
He parried, [INAUDIBLE] blazing
on his sword, sparks flying.
But the creature
was far stronger.
Roban was forced back and
then flung down the steps.
Swatted like a fly, he
disappeared into the shadows
as if he had never been.
"As Roban fell, Clariel swung
her [INAUDIBLE] two-handed
at the creature's back.
But the steel could
not even break
that strange, blood red skin.
It melted as it hit, the
metal rolling in molten
drops as if Clariel had
cast a cup of quicksilver
against the creature
rather than struck it
with a finely tended blade.
The creature turned and
tilted its head quizzically.
"'Not even a sorcerer's sword.
[INAUDIBLE] true.
You do not need such things.
Let me show you how to find
the power within yourself.
I will guide you.
But first, let me dispose of
this small Aborsen.' It strode
over to where Bel lay
half in the fire pit,
its blade feet striking sparks
from the stone as it trod.
It raised on of those
feet above Bel's head,
and was about to bring it down
when Clariel screamed and dived
forward, grabbing that unearthly
spiked foot with both hands
to hold back the killing blow.
"The moment she touched
it, she felt a shock
through her whole body.
Her heart raced in panic
as some unseen force
flowed from the
creature into her.
It entered her mind, exerting
a sudden mental pressure that
made her want to let
go, to open her hands
and let the spike drive down.
To help it strike.
"'No trick, Clariel.
No.
I won't let you.' It took all
her willpower to keep her hands
closed, and all her strength
to stop the spiked foot.
Yet despite everything
she could do,
it kept pressing down,
coming closer and closer
to Bel's forehead,
and the Charter
mark there, as if that was
the spot where the young man's
skull was thinnest.
"'You are strong,' said the
voice inside Clariel's head.
'But not strong enough.'"
There's a little
sample of "Clariel."
We'll go to questions
in a moment,
but shortly before I do
that, I might just quickly
mention something about
the virtue of persistence.
And I guess why I'm here
today talking about my books.
And also because I want to
show off an incredibly low tech
speaking aid which it
amuses me to do in Google.
This is my very first
book, "The Ragwitch."
It was published when I was 26.
And like a lot of
people, I thought
when this book came out,
it would change my life.
It would sell lots and
lots and lots of copies
and I could just write books,
and I could give up my day job.
But it didn't, actually.
I mean, it did change
my life, but not
in the ways that I
expected, I guess.
I thought it would have a
much greater and more dramatic
change.
Because it did OK.
It got good reviews.
Sold a bit.
Sold out its first print
run, but it didn't really
do anything.
I certainly couldn't
give up my day job.
And after I wrote
"The Ragwitch,"
I wrote another book called
"The Clearing House," which
you will not find in
my Wikipedia entry.
No one's ever heard of.
And even after my first
novel was published,
I couldn't get my
next novel published.
I thought it was
a wonderful idea.
Everyone else thought it was
an incredibly stupid idea,
unfortunately.
And I could easily have
given up at that point.
And, in fact, I did consider.
I thought, oh, well.
I've written one.
It got published.
Nothing much happened.
I've written a second one.
It's obviously
not going to work.
It was a bit like that
"Monty Python" sketch
about I built a castle and
it sank into the swamp.
I built another castle,
I built a third
castle, it burned down
and sank into the swamp.
But he built a fourth castle.
And, of course,
I did keep going.
Partially I kept going
because a friend of mine
said to me, well, Garth.
I guess you're just
a one book wonder.
He's a good friend,
surprisingly enough.
And I thought to
myself, I really
don't want to be
a one-book wonder.
I'm going to keep
writing, because you never
know what can happen.
And I did keep writing.
And my next book was "Sabriel."
And "Sabriel," actually,
was also not immediately
an enormous success.
But it kept on going.
It got very good reviews
and people liked it.
But it was not a best seller.
In fact, "Sabriel"
by itself has never
been on any best
seller lists by itself.
But it's sold the most copies
of any of my books by far.
But just over a
long period of time.
The series as a whole has
been on the best seller lists.
And, in fact, back on
"The New York Times"
list this Sunday, which I'm
incredibly pleased about.
So even then, "Sabriel"
was not a big success.
I had to keep my day job.
But I kept on going.
So I could have given
up after "The Ragwitch,"
but I kept going.
And I kept going.
Can I get you to hold this?
That's very kind.
I kept going.
And I kept going.
And through the Old Kingdom
books, "Shade's Children,"
"Keys to the Kingdom,"
"Seventh Tower," then the Keys.
I kept going.
I'm probably causing--
but I kept going.
And I kept going.
I'm causing technical
difficulty now.
And I kept going.
And thank you, Stefan.
Normally I just lay
this on the floor.
And I kept going to
"Clariel," of course,
the most recent book.
I've cheated
slightly, because you
may notice I've used some double
covers here and there to make
this look even more impressive.
But I like to think, when I look
at this big chain of covers,
that it could all
have stopped back
at "The Ragwitch,"
if I'd given up.
Every book is a new possibility.
Every book offers the
opportunity for something
to happen.
And keeping going
potentially opens new doors.
You never know what will
happen if you persevere.
So I like to show this
whole line of books
off, because they easily, so
easily, have stopped early.
And the other reason I made
this is because one day I'm
going to take it to
my friend who told me
I was a one book wonder, and I'm
going to strangle him with it.
Of course, that might
be too easy to work out
who exactly did it.
And, of course, it's also
a very low-tech speaking
aid which can work anywhere.
So I like to show it off.
And this is probably a good
spot to go to questions.
Thank you very much.
I folded it wrong again.
So even though it's low-tech,
I have difficulties with it.
There we go.
Thank you very much.
So, questions?
We've got a microphone.
Might just grab my water.
Of course, the Australian
in the room has to be first,
is that right?
AUDIENCE: That's right.
You collaborated with Sean
Williams quite recently.
[INAUDIBLE] why, I
guess, recently you
have the ability to?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
I've written four books with
my friend Sean Williams,
the "Troubletwisters" series.
And we're going to
write some more.
Not "Troubletwisters,"
which is complete.
We're going to write
some other stories.
It actually came
about because Sean
and I have been friends
for a very long time.
We met at the Brisbane Writers'
Festival, where we bonded over
a disturbing
incident in one panel
we were on, where a very
unsettled person suddenly
started raving at the audience
about being captured by aliens.
And we were science
fiction writers,
so it was somehow our fault.
And he had a huge
green bag which
looked like it was full of guns.
And we were actually
quite disturbed.
Luckily, he just stopped
mid-rant and left, much
to relief of everyone
in the audience.
So we bonded back then.
And we had actually been
talking about writing something
together for years
and years and years,
just because it would be fun.
Because writing is
a solitary activity.
You need to be OK with that.
You need to be able to
work by yourself on things.
I think many authors
like the idea
of working with somebody
else because it would be fun.
And we talked about lots and
lots of different things.
And, in fact, at
different times have
kicked around different ideas.
We looked at a couple
of screenplay ideas.
We looked at some
other story ideas
before we were at a
writers' festival together.
I think it was in Melbourne,
but I can't be absolutely sure.
It may have been a world fantasy
convention somewhere entirely
not in Australia.
And I had a very basic idea
for a children's story.
And I was telling him
about it, and then he
said, well, Garth,
you could do this.
You could do that.
We started talking.
Or this could happen.
And within two or three
hours and a few Guinnesses,
we'd worked out the
story to a basic degree.
But we decided, yeah,
let's write this together.
So it really came
about because we
thought it'd be fun
to write something.
And it has been.
It's been a lot of fun.
And it makes a nice change from
just working on our own books.
But that said, I think it's
actually very important
that we also have our own books
and that that team writing
project is not our
total investment.
It's not the whole thing.
Because that raises all kinds
of other issues, I think.
Where if all your
energies, all your identity
is fixed in your dual
writing team stuff,
I think that's considerably
harder than where
it's something you do as
well as your other books.
And we also, from
the very beginning.
also worked out
how it would work.
We had a writing
agreement in place.
I worked in publishing for
a long time in parallel
with being a writer.
I was an editor and I was
an agent for a long time.
I'm still, in fact, a
shareholder in an agency.
So I'm very aware
of how things can
go wrong with writing
duos or writing groups.
And one of the key
principles, of course,
is always to make
sure that you have
an agreement from the very
beginning which sets out
how the business would work.
What the shares are.
Who will have the final say
if you can't agree on things,
both in terms of the writing
and in terms of the business.
Always [INAUDIBLE] going
with your eyes open.
AUDIENCE: So I've
always been confused
about the "Confusion
of Princes."
It's not like you're known
for princes at this time.
So where did the
"Confusion" come from?
GARTH NIX: The "Confusion
of Princes," I think,
comes from-- that's
my space opera novel.
I love space operas.
I wanted to write one.
It's because there are so many
princes that they-- I mean,
partly it's just because
I really liked the title.
And I think it's not meant to
have a literal interpretation.
But in that particular universe,
there are 10 million princes.
So there could
easily be a confusion
over any particular prince.
There's no specific confusion.
I think if you have
got 10 million princes,
I think a confusion would
be a collective noun.
I think it could become
a collective noun.
If you had 10 million
princes, I think
that would be fair enough.
I hope that kind of
answers, or dodges
the question
sufficiently to move on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a
very small question.
You have many, many
awesome characters.
But my favorite is Yrael.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a cat now?
GARTH NIX: I don't
have a cat now.
In fact, when people
ask me about Mogget,
I always say,
Mogget is, in fact,
based upon all the
cats I've ever known.
Whereas the Disreputable
Dog in Lirael Abhorsen,
her dog-like characteristics
are very specifically
based upon one particular
dog, my parents' dog
and thus a family
dog called Bytenix.
And "Lirael" is, in fact,
dedicated to Bytenix.
So I took very specific
dog-like characteristics
for Disreputable Dog from
one dog in particular.
But Mogget is all the cats.
We had a cat called Jimmy, for
example, when I was a child.
And Jimmy probably
actually was an influence,
because he thought he was human.
He didn't think he was a cat.
He thought he was a human
and behaved accordingly.
So I'm sure that actually
had some influence
as well to the
character of Mogget.
Because, of course,
he's not just a cat.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GARTH NIX: He's also an
element of power, basically.
AUDIENCE: I just
wondered, did you
have a really bad
experience with a cat?
Like, you got to get
this into a book.
GARTH NIX: Well, I think
seriously he is all the cats.
So Jimmy, my childhood cat.
We had a black cat we adopted
for a while-- it was very sad,
he'd run over-- who was
completely wild that
was coming to eat
every now and again.
When I first moved to Sydney,
there was a neighboring cat.
It was actually a grown cat
that looked like a kitten.
He was incredibly cute.
And it used to come visit us.
And we worked it
much later on, it
visited three or
four houses along
and be fed in all of the houses.
And also he used to
smell of wood smoke.
And was called Little Puss.
Little Puss would come in.
Oh, it's wood smoke.
The cat smells of wood smoke.
And we worked out that's because
he spent most of the day lying
next to the fire at the
neighbor's, a couple
of doors down during winter.
AUDIENCE: Smart cat.
GARTH NIX: Yeah.
Cats work out.
They work out where the
best deal is, and they go.
So all those cats.
All those cats had
input, I'm sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In "Keys to the
Kingdom," the mundane setting
is the quarantine and a
military intervention.
And that seems like a very dark
focus on the mundane setting as
opposed to a magic setting.
What inspired that?
[INAUDIBLE] setting for
even mundane aspects?
GARTH NIX: That's
a good question.
I'm not entirely sure,
except that, of course,
I get ideas from
history and from what's
happening in the world and
what's happening around me,
and from the natural world.
There's all these
different inputs
into the reservoir in my head.
And I think probably
I was thinking,
I was writing those
books around the time,
I think, the whole
bird flu scare.
Before then, actually.
I guess I've always
been fascinated
and afraid of that kind of
viral outbreak situation,
and so I just wanted
to put it into a book.
But I'm not exactly sure why.
I don't always know.
And, in fact, I generally don't
know where ideas come from
or why I put things in books
except that it's instinct.
I start thinking
about something.
I think, what would be
happening in this world?
And in the case
there, what would
be happening in the real world?
And I also wanted it
to be near future,
and that was something that came
to mind as a marker of that,
perhaps.
But I'm driven by story.
I thought it was
right for the story.
It seemed cool for the story.
So I wanted to put it in.
And I guess also,
probably I was thinking
about the impingement
of different worlds
and how that would
bring in diseases.
And going all the way back to
the commentary theory of where
viruses come from, some of
which are scientifically,
I think, very unsound.
But for stories, it's great.
So I think that's
where it came from.
But like almost everything
I do, it's really,
will it work for the story?
If it'll make the story
work, make the story better,
then it stays in.
And if I try something and
it doesn't, then it goes out.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
GARTH NIX: Hi, how are you?
AUDIENCE: Very good.
A lot of time has gone by
since "Abhorsen" came out.
And obviously you've been very
busy with many other projects.
What inspired you to come
back to the series now?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
That's an interesting
question, because people
say to me, what's it like to
come back to the Old Kingdom
after 10 years or 11 years.
But to me, I never left
because these ideas
have been in my head
for a very long time.
And, in fact, "Clariel"
stems from the basic question
I asked myself when I
was writing "Lirael."
And I write-- I particularly
used to write-- long hand.
So I'd write a chapter long
hand and then type it up
in black and red
notebooks like this.
This is, in fact, the
"Mr. Monday" notebook.
And one of the things I do
is I keep track of my word
count each time
I'll type a chapter.
So I'll write it
longhand, type it up.
As I type it, I'll
change it and correct it.
So the first version
on the computer
would, in fact,
be a second draft.
And I keep track
of the word count
and I write the date and so on.
So you can see
here, "Mr. Monday,"
I started on the
13th of April, 2002.
And finished on the 10 of
September, 2002, at 12:55 AM.
Quite handy to know.
There's probably something here
about the viruses and so on.
But I went back and
I had a look to see--
I remembered I'd written a
question to myself about one
of the characters
in "Lirael," which
was part of the
idea for "Clariel."
And I went back
and I had a look.
And I saw that I'd written
a question in, I think,
September 1998.
So the seed of the idea
was there from 1998.
And like all my books, I
spend quite a long time
thinking about them
before I wrote them.
And because I'm always
writing something,
I end up having a queue of
ideas forming, ideas forming up,
things where I've written
quite a lot of notes which
are progressing towards
becoming novels.
Or not, sometimes.
Sometimes they're just sitting
there in a holding pattern.
And then there's the big thing,
which is a crude enough idea
mess that I have to abandon
it and get on with it
and write it.
And "Clariel" was
moving up that queue
and gathering bits
and pieces of ideas
and joining together, up until
about three or four years ago.
It actually got a full place
in the queue where I was like,
this is what I'm going to
do after the book I was then
writing.
So to me, I was with
it the whole time.
But, of course, to readers,
it's been a long time
for which I apologize for
those who felt it was too long.
But that's just the
way that I work.
So the idea for it, the basic
seed for it is very old.
It goes back 16 years.
But just the time to write
it where it was formed enough
was more recent.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: At least you're
not Isobelle Carmody.
[INAUDIBLE]
GARTH NIX: Isobelle Carmody
is an Australian author
who's been writing a
series that I think
began around the same time
as "Sabriel," actually.
So we're talking in
Australia, 20 years ago.
In fact, she might have
been a bit earlier.
22, 23 years ago.
And has still not
written the last book.
Giving George R.R. Martin
a run for his money.
I should tell him that.
AUDIENCE: So I started reading
your books, the "Seventh Tower"
books.
And that was very quick to the
"Keys to the Kingdom" books.
You [INAUDIBLE] at first and
haven't really expanded on it.
So I guess this is
a two part question.
First, do you think you'll
expand those worlds as well
in the future?
And second, is there just
something about the Sabriel
Lirael world that compels
you to expand and return
to those books instead?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
The "Seventh Tower"
books were, in fact,
commissioned by LucasFilm.
They own them.
LucasFilm own the
books completely,
which means Disney now
own the books completely.
So there's an
extremely slim chance
I'll ever do anything
again with those books,
unless I can somehow
wrest them back,
which is incredibly unlikely
considering who owns them.
So the "Seventh Tower,"
I think it's always
impossible I would
ever go back to that.
The "Keys to the Kingdom"
in my mind is complete.
It's a complete story.
It's a complete big story.
That said, I'm always very
reluctant to say I definitely
won't go back, because
you never know.
I think it's unlikely.
There's nothing in
the queue in my head
that is related to those books.
But it's a big world.
Potentially I
could do something.
The Houses is a huge thing.
I could easily find
spaces to write stories.
If the right thing came along,
I might well do something.
But I have no plans at
present to go back to it.
And the second part of
question-- my tired brain's
quite just managed to hold
on to those two questions.
That's as much as I
can hold in my head.
The Old Kingdom
and Ancelstierre,
there's [INAUDIBLE] to
the south of the Wall.
They both offer lots and
lots of room for stories.
And I really like going
back into that world
and discovering
different things myself.
Because I'm the kind
of fantasy writer
that I work things
out as I go along.
I discover the world
as I write the story.
So I'm not one of the writers
who works out the whole world
beforehand, who
plans all the history
and the languages
and the geography.
I just work up what I need and
a little bit more as I go along.
What I need for the story.
I've very story focused.
So for me, going
into the Old Kingdom
is also a voyage of
discovery for me writing it.
So I always really enjoy that.
And, in fact, I am writing
another one right now.
So there will be another Old
Kingdom novel, which hopefully
will be out the year after next.
Again, I'm reluctant
to say for sure.
It won't be 11 years.
Touch whatever this material is.
This opposite.
And that book picks up
from the end of Abhorsen
and from the
Creature in the Case.
So it has Nicholas
and Lirael in it.
But it also connects back to
some of the things in "Clariel"
as well, because it's a big
world which has a cosmology.
So there's lots of
opportunities to write stories
that connect back in
with everything that's
happened before in
some ways, while still
being self-contained stories.
So I'm writing an
Old Kingdom novel.
The next Old Kingdom
story, in fact,
will be out in my next
short story collection which
comes out in May, which is
called "To Hold the Bridge."
And the lead story in that
is an Old Kingdom novelette
called "To Hold the
Bridge," funnily enough.
But it also has stories--
it has a story set
in the world of
"Shade's Children"
called "You Won't Feel a
Thing," which is possibly
the only story
completely worked up
whilst having a root canal
in the endodontist's chair.
No pain, I'm glad to say.
I mean, really, I was super
impressed with modern dentistry
that-- everyone kept telling
me about how painful a root
canal would be.
And I was quite
worried about this.
But there was no pain.
It's just weird.
I was slightly concerned when
the endodontist said to me,
looking at the
x-rays of my tooth.
And she was looking
and she said,
you have very, very long roots.
They're almost off the
bottom of the x-ray.
I'm going to have to borrow
a longer needle from the vet.
She was joking.
But just for a moment, I
had that moment of, oh no.
She's got to get a what?
And that actually
sparked off this story.
And, in fact, that
story is about teeth
with really, really long roots.
Which, of course, in the world
of "Shade's Children," which
is very much a dystopian,
horrendous world,
is a much, much
more horrible thing
than it is in this current era.
And it also has a story in
"A Confusion of Princes"
world too, called "Master
Haddad's Holiday,"
as well as lots of other
collected short fiction
from the last five
or six years which
has been published in
various anthologies.
So the Old Kingdom,
Ancelstierre,
there's a lot of room.
And I've got lots
of ideas for stories
to write in that world, some
of which will be short stories.
Some will be novels.
I hope I get to
write them and I hope
that you will keep reading them.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two
questions, but I'll
give them to you one at a time.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
Thank you for your
consideration.
AUDIENCE: First
question is, is there
any possibility of
a movie coming out
about any of your books?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
There's been lots of
backwards and forwards stuff
over the years.
With "Sabriel," I took
a particular approach,
which is possibly a much higher
stakes approach in the sense
that I wouldn't just sell
an option on the book.
I wanted to be involved more
heavily, because I wanted--
you can't ever ensure
that it'll be a good film,
but the only control you have is
who you sell it to, basically.
So try and work with people
and hope for the best.
So I went down
the path of trying
to find people, put together
a package of people,
which I did back in 2009.
And so we did the
rounds in Hollywood
with-- it was actually
Brad Pitt's company-- Plan
B. And a bridge director.
And I was going to carry out
the screenplay with an Oscar
nominated screenwriter,
great writer.
So it looked great.
It was like we
had a good chance.
And we did the whole go
around the studios thing.
It was 2009.
Interestingly,
almost everybody we
met including the female
heads of the studios,
had a problem with it
being a female protagonist.
And there was a lot of,
when can the guy come in?
You make Touchstone
come in on page five.
When can we bring
him in earlier?
And ultimately, that
was almost set up.
There was a couple places it
went on to quite a long time.
It was like it was
going to happen.
And then it didn't.
Who knows for what reasons.
There's all kinds of reasons.
And then about a year
and a half after that,
it was actually set
up again pretty much
with that same team,
another partner.
It was actually
[INAUDIBLE] Australia,
using Australian tax credits.
And then the Australian
dollar went up.
And there was a question of
whether the tax offset would
apply.
If the tax offset went away,
then $20 million in the budget
went away.
So the whole thing went away.
Which is that world.
That world works like that.
After that, I actually
wrote a screenplay for it.
It was the guy I was
going to write it
with ended up writing a
couple of television shows,
being super successful.
He had no time.
But I talked about it
enough, I wanted to do it.
I hoped that would
help move things along.
So there was a
screenplay of "Sabriel."
At different times, there's
been different combinations
of people trying to set it up.
Right at the moment, there's
an attempt to set it up again.
But who knows.
It's like a lot of books.
Some of them never
get made into films.
Some get made into films 30
years later or 50 years later.
I would love to see it made.
I'd love to see it made
by really good people.
It's out of my control.
I've done everything I can.
On "Shade's
Children," people have
been trying to set it
up for a long time.
There's a New
Zealand horror movie
director who wants to do it.
There's a guy, actually,
a Chinese special effects
guy who wants to
make it in China,
which I think could be amazing.
But he can't get the
money together either.
It's always about money.
Always.
They're not drawing
room comedies
you can make very cheaply.
Though, of course, you can make
them more cheaply now than you
could at one time.
"Keys to the Kingdom" has
been television people
trying to set that up.
So I have a long
history of things
not working out in that regard.
I mean, I often say that
I'm a successful novelist,
but I'm a very
unsuccessful screenwriter.
Because I've also written
original screenplays
that I've tried to set up
which have not, as yet, gotten
set up.
But fingers crossed.
You never know.
I guess one of my
little daydreams
is that somebody who
loved the books growing up
is even now becoming a
great director whose films I
will love.
And, in turn, they
love my books.
And they'll be so powerful
that the studio will go, yes.
Whatever you want to make.
You want to make "Sabriel."
You loved it when you were 12.
Sure.
Go for it.
And I'll be like,
I love their films.
This is fantastic.
So that could happen.
It's a daydream.
A good daydream. [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I hope
that does work out.
My second question.
So I read "Sabriel"
at a very young age.
And it ruined me.
It set the bar so high.
And so--
GARTH NIX: I'm not sure if I
should apologize [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But as obviously a
writer of excellent fantasy,
who do you like to read?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
Well, I read all kinds.
I mean, I do read
fantasy but I probably
read more other stuff,
particularly now.
And that's just how things
have developed, I suppose.
I do go through periods
of reading fantasy,
trying to catch up.
Which is impossible, of course.
So I read a lot of non-fiction.
I read a lot of other
kinds of fiction.
I read a lot of thrillers
and historical novels.
And I re-read a lot.
I love re-reading.
But in terms of fantasy,
one of my big favorite
contemporary fantasy
writers is Guy Gavriel Kay.
I've just re-read
his "River of Stars,"
which is a wonderful,
wonderful novel.
I've not read anything
else, but anyone else
could easily read it, of course.
I mean, my books, I think, are
not necessarily [INAUDIBLE].
Publisher categorization is not
really what books are about.
It's where it's most
convenient to sell them.
And so Guy Gavriel Kay's--
almost any of his books.
But "Under Heaven"
and "River of Stars."
He just gets better.
He's one of those
really annoying people
who just gets better and better.
I mean that in a good way.
So I love his fantasy works.
Holly Black.
I just read "The Coldest
Girl in Coldtown."
I like that quite a lot.
Who else have I read
recently in the genre.
Maggie Stiefvater's
"The Scorpio Races,"
which is a really good book, and
very different kind of fantasy.
It's really interesting.
But I think going back, there's
many classic fantasy writers
I love.
And particularly some
of the influences
on "Sabriel," I
think, which deserve
looking at, like Robin McKinley,
"The Blue Sword" and "The Hero
and the Crown," I think,
were a big influence.
Ursula Le Guin, of course.
"Wizard of Earthsea" and
"The Tombs of Atuan,"
perhaps even more so.
Susan Cooper. "The Dark
is Rising," her books.
Alan Garner, a British
fantasy writer [INAUDIBLE]
which I read very often.
And his book, "The Owl
Service." "The Owl Service"
is such a strange fantasy.
It's so powerful,
and it's so lyrical.
And I've often said if I could
write anything half the way
as good as the last 3
pages of "The Owl Service,"
I'll be a very,
very, happy writer.
That's the bar
really high, I think.
really, really high.
But there's so many.
I mean, what are some
of your favorites?
AUDIENCE: You named a couple.
I like Diana Wynne Jones.
GARTH NIX: Oh, I love
Diana Wynne Jones.
AUDIENCE: Contemporary.
GARTH NIX: Yeah.
In fact, I just
read the last book
which her sister finished,
"The Islands of Chaldea."
It just came Ursula Jones, which
is very interesting because you
can't tell where her sister
took over, which I think
is a testament to both of them.
But yeah, I loved
her stuff growing up.
I love re-reading it now.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: Oh, boy.
Of course, Ursula Le Guin.
GARTH NIX: Putting
you on the spot.
AUDIENCE: You are
putting me on the spot.
I didn't expect this.
GARTH NIX: When you
ask em these questions,
my mind goes
completely blank even
though I've been
asked quite often.
There's so many.
AUDIENCE: There are too many.
GARTH NIX: Lloyd
Alexander is a great name.
Again, going back.
But there's many fantastic
contemporary writers as well.
There's always so many
good books around.
Old ones, new ones, one that
will come out next week.
We're lucky to have such a--
there are ones that are not
so good as well, of course--
but there are so many good ones.
So much to read.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Earlier
this week, we were
joined by Chris Baty, who's
the founder of National Novel
Writing Month, in which
people will try and write
a novel during November.
I was wondering, of
that mind, if you
could talk a little bit about
your own writing process
and maybe offer some advice
for a budding novelist.
GARTH NIX: Sure.
Sure.
Well, I think NaNoWriMo's
a great thing to do.
And it seems to help a lot of
people break out of some habits
and so on, and find new habits.
In terms of my own writing,
I write half my novel,
the first dozen or so
novels that I wrote,
I wrote while I had
a very busy day job.
And I would write just a couple
of hours two nights a week.
And I would try and
write three or four
hours on the Saturday or Sunday.
And I would try to be
quite [INAUDIBLE] about it
and really keep
to that schedule.
If do that, in a year
or a year and a half,
you can write a book.
Sometimes writers
get up and they say,
this is how you write a novel.
And it's how they write a novel.
Or it's how they wrote
their last novel.
It may not actually
apply to you.
So I always recommend
to people, take anything
a writer says with
a grain of salt.
It may or may not apply
to your own writing.
I think it's important to
always bear that in mind.
So if you do something
which is exactly
the opposite of what
someone has told you to do,
that may actually be fine.
So whatever works.
And try different things.
Try different ways of writing.
I do think finding a routine
of some kind is good,
but it doesn't have
to be get up at 4 AM
and write for two hours.
That's the only way.
Or write two nights a week.
It could be, I don't know.
You could work it out.
But then since I've
been a full time writer,
I've flipped that
around and I actually
write during office hours.
I have a separate office.
I had two separate offices
in a different home--
I also worked at
home and I still
work at home to some
degree, in the spare bedroom
in the corner, as
was as in my office.
And what I try to
do is I don't set
myself word count targets,
though I do keep track of them,
like in "Mr. Monday."
I will keep track
of each chapter
as the first draft is finished.
Particularly I do like looking
at the numbers going up.
It's encouraging.
And also one of the
things i do is I never
tell myself I'm writing a novel.
I never tell myself, right.
Today I sit down and I
write 100,000 word novel,
because that's a lot of words.
I say, I'm going
to write a chapter.
A chapter is two or
three or maybe 4,000.
And that's doable.
It feels to me that's
a discrete task.
I won't try to do
it all in one go.
Some people say, you
have to do 1,000 words
before you can get up and go
have a coffee or whatever.
I don't do that.
But when I do sit down to
write in my writing routine,
I try and write a sizable
chunk of something.
And then when I feel
like it's time to stop,
I make myself do
a little bit more.
I make myself write a bit more
than the first time I decided,
oh, I've had enough of this.
And I also sometimes
do-- there's
another technique
people always recommend,
which is never get up when
you've finished a chapter
or finished a discrete piece of
writing, a scene or a sequence
in a screenplay.
Never get up and say
whoa, I'm done with that
and get up straightaway
and start drinking
or whatever you do.
But actually write a little
bit of the next thing.
So if you've written a chapter,
write the first paragraph
of the next chapter
and then get up
and do whatever you have to do.
And then when you
come back to it,
you've already got
something started.
You don't have to say,
well, what do I do now?
It's already there.
It's already started.
And you've also done it in
the flow of the momentum
that you built up
writing before.
So I think that's a little
trick that can be very helpful.
And I think there are
issues with momentum.
The more you do, the
more you will do.
The more you've written,
the faster it gets.
And the other thing I'll say
is that I typically really hate
my books around about halfway
through, sometimes earlier.
And this is quite normal.
Almost every writer
I know, in fact,
hates their books
at different times.
And often it's
around the middle.
And so I will complain to
my wife, who's a publisher.
So it's very unfair
having a [INAUDIBLE]
author at home as
well as at work.
And I'll say, ah.
I really hate this book.
And I've forgotten how to write.
I don't know.
How did I write
those other books?
Whatever I used to be able
to do, I can't do it anymore.
It's hopeless.
This whole book sucks.
I can't go on.
And then if I complain
to her, she'll
remind me that I always do this.
When she's not around,
I'm just doing it myself.
I'll remind myself that
I always feel like this.
And the only answer to it is
ti go back and keep going.
And typically you look back and
it's not as bad as you think,
and also you can fix it up.
Because revision's
such an important part
of the whole writing process.
Even when you've
written something
that you think is great and
you're really happy about it,
it's always worth
going back to it.
It's always worth going
back to it at some point.
And typically what happens
is you write something
and you think it's really
terrible and you hate it.
Or you think it's really
great and you love it.
Probably neither of those
things is entirely true.
So it's always
important to go back.
Revise.
Sometimes you have
to go back a lot.
What i often do-- another
little technique that I do.
Again, this may or may not work.
Is that I typically will read
what I wrote the day before,
before I start
writing the next bit.
And as I'm reading it,
I will also revise it.
So my first chapters
are typically
revised as many
chapters there are
chapters in the book, at least.
SO if it's a 35 chapter
book, the first chapter
will have been revised 35 times.
And the last chapter, it won't
have been revised only once.
But it will have been
revised two or three times.
Partially, that's because
the momentum build
and I get faster
and more assured.
And I know the story
better, and my excitement
builds up as I get
towards the end.
Again, I can look back
on my [INAUDIBLE].
It's "Grim Tuesday" in the back.
And I can see looking
at that, that I wrote
the first-- it's
got 23 chapters.
I wrote the first
half in six months,
and I wrote the second
half in 5 weeks.
So momentum builds.
So forcing yourself
back to work,
or looking at what you've
written and carrying on,
always going a bit further
than you think you need to.
All those things, I
think, work very well.
And I think NaNoWriMo
is a great thing to do.
And you never know if you can
write a novel until you try.
And a lot more people,
I think, can write.
A lot of people think they
can't because it's too long.
But they've never
actually tried.
I think if you try,
you never know.
Unless you've written, you never
know what can happen as well.
Every new book is
a new opportunity.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GARTH NIX: Thank you.
Good luck.
Are you doing NaNoWriMo?
AUDIENCE: I am, yes.
GARTH NIX: Good luck.
Read Scott
Westerfeld's book, too,
"Afterworlds,"
which is quite new.
It's all about writing
novels and the first novel.
It's a story.
It's a novel.
But it's in that world, writing
novels and NaNoWriMo and stuff.
AUDIENCE: Good to know.
Thanks.
GARTH NIX: Yeah.
Cheers.
AUDIENCE: I was
just curious where
the inspiration for
the names-- like,
Sabriel, Lirael, Clariel--
there's clearly a theme there.
But how do you come up with
the names for your characters?
GARTH NIX: Sure.
Well Sabriel, Clariel, Lirael,
and so on, they deliberately
hearken back and resonate
with angels' names.
They use the Hebrew "ael"
"iel" endings recursively.
Sabriel, when I was
making up that name,
I did probably 20 or 30
different combinations,
different word combinations.
And what I'm
normally looking for
is something that resonates
in a particular way.
And whether the reader's
aware of it or not,
it will suggest
to them something.
And, of course, using those
Hebrew word components
of angels' names
actually suggests
something mysterious
and powerful.
It sounds like an angel's name.
Angels are mysterious
and powerful.
These connections are
made inside of your head.
And you may or may
not be aware of it.
So that's a very
deliberate choice.
But I spent a lot of time
combining different pieces
of words to make names that not
only have the right resonance,
but also sound right.
So I'll say them
aloud a lot until I
find a name that works for
me, and it feels right.
It feels like it
carries the right weight
for who the character will be.
So that's how I
make up the names.
But I will say, I steal names.
Abhorsen comes from Shakespeare.
Abhorsen in "Measure for
Measure" is an executioner.
And when I was looking for
the name of the family,
Sabriel's family, and I
wanted an executioner's name.
I was looking back
through history and myth,
and looking for different
names of famous executioners.
And I couldn't find
one that worked for me.
And then quite accidentally,
I was reading "Measure
for Measure" and there was
Abhorsen, an executioner.
And I thought, there's the name.
Shakespeare stole a
name, so I can do it too.
Thank you.
Any more questions, or
are all done for now?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]